[Music]  Celebrity Big Brother is finally coming  to the US this February we think we know  famous people because of the roles that  they play on the big screen or the small  screen what I'm looking forward to is  seeing what happens you know behind the  magic behind the hair makeup behind the  curtains and CBS announced the cast in a  blink and you miss it promo just before  the 2018 Grammy Awards  yeah hard to catch all of those faces  but we got you covered  the 11 of famous faces entering the Big  Brother house will be Shannon Elizabeth  Ross Matthews Brandi Glanville keshia  knight pulliam Metta World Peace miss  Colombia  2015 Ariadna Gutierrez James Maslow  Marissa Jaret Winokur Sugar Ray's mark  McGrath Omarosa Manigault Andy UFC champ  Chuck Liddell I'm looking forward to  getting to know even if it's a celebrity  that you know isn't really on my radar I  just want to see the human side of you  know  [Music]